welcome to this video playing zetts TFS
from Switzerland m going for the Dutch
again I'd like to play that a couple of
times here trying to get a better feel
for the positions and playing this funny
line this is called there's a funny name
the Christmas tree variation and yeah I
don't know why it is called like that
what about this he tries to go for a
quickie form what about this maybe I
bring up a lot wrong wrong wrong kind of
phrase being ready for the opening of
the position by pressurizing deform okay
so let's go here
it's not exactly what I expected to be
honest do you one in prep then then you
for okay fields a bit a bit strange to
remove the look from afar there ok let's
let's open that up Bishop g4 for example
gets more pumps or it gets more
problematic yeah I caught it sorry a
slight cold him
not so clear what the rook is doing on
d1 here if it plays d5 um okay he played
it so Bishop f5 was my idea yeah that's
probably right and care about the
details later it's night before the
right move him that's an interesting
question not before I might have night
age form but still in going back to be a
distant isn't a good idea probably
a 3 92 190 for winning the exchange I
guess so 83 is not a 3 is coming so he
wants to play Oh what is he going to do
so look a tool
if I gunite ATM that's a very in very
funny kind of position here night see to
look a to but ok I can I can play that
anyway I mean 94 as always possible if I
have moved the Queen where do I put it
it's also a four in the in the position
before here is an interesting move in
case of an item they have 94
even Bishop c4 is a move
hmm
how to decide it's really difficult to
decide what's right him let's do this
I'm really unsure really unsure
yeah that was one idea have to get the
Queen out tempo on f3 and have 94 now h3
was I don't know what what exactly
wasn't high on my list of candidates but
playable so jump here
Knight f3 coming but not sure how much
that is h5 is also in okay that was also
also in project possible check there but
this is kind of elonia the bishop is not
really supported well
okay let's prevent that King age seven
bishop age six is also an IDM okay yeah
I definitely return the exchange here or
not I Scott rookie to now but still I
have to return the exchange can be
actually quite quite happy that I was
able to do that Queen f5 you can take
lucky seven don't want that
so create enough here or not I can't get
Queen f3 is actually interesting yeah
that's the interesting the deep horn is
quite quite quick ok I can maybe take
rupee 8th route f8 rookie 70 not sure ok
he has to trade first maybe it's playing
something else entirely nope yeah check
King h7 rookie seven looks wrong for me
it's going there ok here i have this one
72 rock-beetle Roxy five rook g7 yeah
but I wanted to go look see two anyway
Bishop is kind of a kind of in trouble
him doesn't have any squares nope no
squares
white resigns okay so it was it was very
very complicated 25 d 5 so we got this
now we went 83 surprisingly here group
here and this is a very very tricky
situation I really don't know what to do
because there are many interesting
looking moves there Bishop gvoice wanna
ultimately play but there are some other
moves before I for example is
interesting yet it looks weird because
it disconnects the mind but it also
texts the night however i'm in opinion
so it's a very strange position I
couldn't really figure it out if he
moves the night I have this one I don't
know if he has to move the night at the
Queen doesn't have many squares though
something like that I have Bishop g4 it
was very interesting as well I could
really couldn't couldn't describe decide
I was surprised about a tree though
because I wanted to do that anyway this
capture I interesting engine gives this
move route takes rook chick that's
interesting this is definitely quite
interesting for white to black I'm sorry
the e-file aunt is somewhat awkward
pieces that was Rosa was a valid
alternative and here and not i'm not
sure about this is this now looks a bit
a bit weird
yeah I don't think this is enough but
check he has some here some compensation
there may be Queen l3r ever seems to win
tweener three again yeah I I think I
underestimated the power of the deep on
the deep one is really quick then Shrive
queen bee three and now i can give it
back yeah I just wanted to get rid of
this here chick sticks to Queen f3 so he
can draw with the check yeah that was
better right check control with that so
that was my mistake that allowed that
here we should beat was even a problem
just much better to have this year that
was that was the reason why queena 3 was
bad I have to play rupee aid and then
it's really mostly just upon yeah the so
I play to play Banda him without aruki 7
it should be okay again right Bishop a
4k and after that I'm winning yeah yeah
so some errors yet there are some
mistakes at the end of the game but
that's an interesting variation here
this esox line it's very m it's a bit
unconventional but not not bad at all ok
well thanks for watching